I choose to live by choice not by chance
you can only fight the way you practice
if there isn't discipline How can there
be a true realization of an ideal
one thousand days of lessons for
discipline Ten Thousand Days of lessons
for Mastery
[Music]
the path that leads to truth is littered
with the bodies of the ignorant
[Music]
to win any battle you must fight as if
you were already dead
[Music]
no fear no hesitation no surprise No
Doubt
[Music]
get Beyond love and grief exist for the
good of man
[Music]
you must understand that there is more
than one path to the top of the mountain
do nothing which is of no use
[Music]
it may seem difficult at first but
everything is difficult at first
do not fear death
do not regret what you have done
[Music]
technique by itself is insufficient and
spirit alone is not enough
[Music]
a samurai is essentially a man of action
I worship dead men for their strength
forgetting I was strong
[Music]
sword and mind must be United
self-respect is the fruit of discipline
we make war that we may live in peace
true meaning of the Samurai is one who
serves and adheres to the power of love
everyone feels fear what a samurai or
Warrior is is what you do when you feel
fear
a samurai must remain calm at all times
even in the face of danger
one mind any weapon
today is victory over yourself of
yesterday tomorrow is your victory over
lesser men
[Music]
The Way of the Samurai is found in death
having only wisdom and talent is the
lowest tier of usefulness
matters of small concern should be
treated seriously
a samurai will use a toothpick even
though he has not eaten
inside the skin of a dog outside the
height of a tiger
[Music]
there is nothing we should be so
grateful for as the last line of the
poem that goes when your own heart asks
[Music]
single-mindedness is all-powerful
[Music]
continue to Spur A running horse
[Music]
meaning of etiquette is quick at both
the beginning and the end and tranquil
in the middle
[Music]
greatness is not the absence of humility
it is the absence of apathy
[Music]
there will never be peace on Earth until
there is peace in US
[Music]
the warrior knows that their imagination
is not a place to escape but to create
[Music]
the fool lives to consume all they can
take from the world
the wise lives to create a better world
[Music]
we will never know peace if we lose the
present because we are trapped in the
past and Paralyzed by the future
knowledge becomes such only when it is
assimilated in the mind of the learner
and shows in his character
[Music]
the sense of Honor which cannot bear
being looked down upon as an inferior
power that is the strongest of motives
beneath the instinctified their looks
are diviner instinct to love
[Music]
chivalry is itself The Poetry of life
dishonor is like a scar on a tree which
time instead of it facing only helps to
enlarge
you are to be proud of your enemy then
the success of your enemy is your
success also
human life has sorrow
they who meet must part he that is born
Must Die
[Music]
think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the world
it is good to face challenges in your
youth he who has never suffered will not
sufficiently temper his character
[Music]
I have a high art I hurt with cruelty
those who would damage me
Master the Divine techniques of the art
of peace and no enemy will dare to
challenge you
[Music]
The Ultimate Warrior leaves no openings
except in his mind
the sword has to be more than a simple
weapon it has to be an answer to Life's
questions
Master the Divine techniques of the art
of peace and no enemy will dare to
challenge you
you might as well stand and fight
because if you run you will only die
tired
a samurai should always be prepared for
death whether his own or someone else's
[Music]
where life is more terrible than death
it is then the truest Valor to Dare to
Live
[Music]
study hard and all things can be
accomplished give up and you will amount
to nothing
observation and perception are two
separate things
the eye that observes is stronger the
eye that perceives is weaker
engage in combat fully determined to die
and you will live wish to survive in
battle and you will surely die
loyalty and devotion lead to bravery
bravery leads to the spirit of
self-sacrifice the spirit of
self-sacrifice creates Trust In The
Power of Love
foreign
or the martial arts you must live
intensely wholeheartedly without Reserve
as if you might die in the next instant
their attitude towards life was that of
those who always strive to be better
and they saw spirituality as the path to
achieve greatness
spiritual service be it a priest or
teacher was not to be repaid in gold or
silver not because it was valueless but
because it was invaluable
the feeling of distress is the root of
benevolence therefore a benevolent man
is ever mindful of those who are
suffering and in distress
[Music]
never trust a man who tells you all his
troubles but keeps from you all his joys
[Music]
mental bearing calmness not skill is a
sign of a mature Samurai
a samurai therefore should neither be
pompous nor arrogant
the only reason a warrior is alive is to
fight and the only reason a warrior
fights is to win
otherwise why be a warrior
it is easier to count beads
I don't get over the Wonder of it and
The Last Samurai was an extreme example
of that
every day when I went to the set I
couldn't believe what I was seeing
foreign